[Musique]
bonsoir le journal de la rédaction de tv
78 pour faire le tour d'horizon de
l'actualité locale bienvenue dans cette
édition du mardi 10 mars voici les
titres le collier 19 fait ses premières
victimes dans les yvelines deux
personnes de l'ehpad le coeur volant à
louveciennes placé en confinement depuis
dimanche sont décédés à versailles les
autorités ont décidé de fermer huit
classes de l'école élémentaire l'ulimo
banc une enseignante de musique a été
diagnostiquée positive au virus
toujours à versailles hier 150 jeunes
ont réalisé leur journée défense et
citoyenneté à la caserne d'artois un
rendez vous placé sous le signe des
droits des femmes au lendemain de la
journée mondiale dédiée
et puis l'actualité des municipales
premier tour au programme ce dimanche ce
soir présentation des candidats aux
clayes-sous-bois reportage avec sylvie
ce vin montella villepreux et puis
invité erwan le gall en course à
maurepas à la fin de ce journal nous
parlerons aussi de la quinzaine des
possibles qui débute ce demain à
rambouillet le couronnent le coronavirus
fait donc ses premiers morts dans les
yvelines deux résidents de la maison de
retraite korian le coeur volant à
louveciennes sont décédés aujourd'hui
c'est la mairie de la ville qui l'a
annoncé vous le voyez par le biais de
son compte twitter est depuis dimanche
l'établissement a été placé en
confinement par la rs suite à la
découverte de quatre cas un personal un
personnel soignant de remplacement
seraient à l'origine de la contamination
est la municipalité de lucian a
d'ailleurs confirmé ce mardi qu'au moins
un nouveau patient était infectée au
dernier point de la rs paru ce mardi à
17 heures quarante sept cas étaient
recensés dans les yvelines quasiment le
double par rapport à hier
chaque jour le nombre de contamination
augmente considérablement dans le
département où deux centres de
diagnostic sont installés au centre
hospitalier de versailles aussi sur
celui de poissy et après la fermeture
des écoles de l'école et des sablons à
poissy c'est au tour est de 8 classes de
l'école élémentaire lully vauban à
versailles de faire de même pour 14
jours une enseignante de musique a été
attestée positivo coville 19 ce matin la
rectrice de l'académie de versailles
s'est rendu sur place
le reportage de mathilde et demi et de
patrick jacques de dixmude à la décision
ne faisait plus de doute après le test
positif au coronavirus d'une enseignante
de musique lundi 9 mars les autorités
ont acté la fermeture de huit classes à
l'école élémentaire lully vauban à
versailles
la rectrice de l'académie a rencontré
les professeurs pour échanger avec eux
des mesures à prendre et de la
continuité pédagogique a assuré les
éléments de la continuité pédagogique
c'est permettre à chaque enfant pendant
les 15 jours qui sont devant nous
d'avoir accès
à des contenus et à son programme donc
on fait les enseignants ici eh bien ils
ont mis en place un blog en effet
j'ai vivement conseillé aux enseignants
d'essayer la classe virtuelle la classe
virtuelle c'est un ordinateur devant soi
on a face à soi l'ensemble des élèves
lesquels peuvent lever la main à
intervenir
on a un tableau sur lequel on peut
écrire et donc être dans une
configuration de classe tout à fait tout
à fait normal suite au confinement de
l'enseignante qui a contracté le
qu'ovide 19 le corps enseignant a de
suite réagi en créant un blog pour
fournir du travail aux élèves isolé ça
du coup les enseignants vont pouvoir
déposer du contenu pédagogique à savoir
des extraits de manuel qu'ils ont pu
scanner ou pris en photo des exercices à
faire en plus des vidéos à regarder sur
différents sites notamment en anglais et
puis d'autres choses en fonction de leur
projet de classe les parents d'élèves
confiné ont pu trouver sur le site de
l'école le lien du blog celui classe sur
18 ont été fermées à l'école lully
vauban le directeur a reçu dans la
matinée les parents inquiets certains
soirs et quai
certains assurent dans la compréhension
pourquoi telle classe les bras c'est
pourquoi pas telle autre
or leur expliquer que c'était les
classes qui avaient été en contact avec
l'enseignante en question l'état de
santé de l'enseignante de musique
n'inspire pas d'inquiétude selon la
préfecture les classes concernées
resteront fermées pendant 14 jours les
élèves pourront revenir à compter du 20
mars et cette enseignante intervient
également dans le conservatoire régional
de musique de versailles dans un
communiqué l' agence régionale de santé
et la mairie recommande donc la
fermeture de sept groupes de la
structure qui ont été en contact avec
l'enseignante pendant sa période de
contagiosité 176 élèves du conservatoire
sont concernés et ont été invités à
rester chez eux pendant une période de
14 jours
et forcément en raison de l'interdiction
des rassemblements de plus de 1000
personnes dans le pays de nombreux
événements sont peu à peu annulées dans
les yvelines
hier nous vous parlions de l'annulation
du mondial du golf et de l'eco-trail à
saint quentin en yvelines les embuscades
poétique moment phare du printemps des
poètes ont été déprogrammés jeudi l'
animation originale prend place dans les
bus de l'agglomération pour déclamer des
poèmes
ce devait être l'un des événements
sportifs phares de ce mois ci le clasico
de ligue à de volley français
les tours ne se déroulera finalement pas
au vélodrome nationale le match était
prévu le 28 mars
plus de 5500 spectateurs étaient
attendus dans les travées pour
l'événement est la foire internationale
de chatou sera elle bien maintenu la
préfecture des yvelines a donné
l'autorisation elle démarre ce vendredi
jusqu'à la fin de la foire le 22 mars le
nombre de visiteurs sera en revanche est
limité à 1000 personnes par jour avec un
décompte à l'entrée le rendez-vous fête
ses 50 ans d'installation dans les
yvelines
et j'ajoute que des sites qui
accueillent du public en nombre ont pris
également leur disposition le château de
versailles par exemple procède
aujourd'hui à une régulation des entrées
le monument conseille d'ailleurs de se
procurer un ebe avec réservation
horaires pour favoriser l accès sur
place voilà ce qu'on pouvait vous dire
sur cette actualité est liée aux
coronavirus dans les yvelines également
dans les titres 150 jeunes franciliens
ont effectué hier leur journée défense
et citoyenneté à la caserne d'artois à
versailles un rendez vous placé sous le
signe des droits des femmes des
témoignages de parcours et d'engagement
ont été proposés aux participants au
rayon c'est une étape obligatoire dans
le parcours de citoyenneté la jdc
journée défense et citoyenneté
concernent chaque année 800 mille jeunes
en france
objectif détecter des situations de
décrochage mais aussi expliquer les
enjeux de la défense
pour cette session à la caserne d'artois
à versailles trois femmes engagées sont
venus témoigner de leur parcours
il faut donner le meilleur de soi voilà
oui effectivement il faut il faut
essayer de faire peut-être un peu plus
mais bon moi j'ai toujours trouvé ça on
va dire plus un challenge motivant de
voir et d'essayer de toujours viser le
haut on soit un homme ou une femme on a
les mêmes difficultés et les mêmes
facilités dans le métier c'est pas parce
qu'on est une femme qu'on peut pas
atteindre ce genre de carrière et avoir
sa place dans ce type de métier durant
une vingtaine de minutes ces femmes
ingénieures sapeurs pompiers ou juristes
ont échangé avec les citoyens de demain
le but montrer qu'il existe de
nombreuses opportunités de carrière dans
ce secteur le taux de féminisation varie
en fonction des armées le service de
santé peut s'enorgueillir d'accueillir
67 % de personnel féminin le service de
commissariat des armées
lui est à 30% l'armée de terre par
exemple compte 10% 10 à 12 % de
personnel féminin parmi ses rangs
mais il faut savoir que toutes les armes
et toutes les armées n'était pas ouverte
au personnel féminin les femmes ont tout
autant le droit de représenter la france
de se battre pour notre pays et j'en
suis fier je suis fier que petit à petit
ça avance en 2012 le ministère des
armées a nommé un haut fonctionnaire à
l'égalité des droits pour valoriser le
personnel féminin
[Musique]
nj - 5 avant le premier tour des
municipales programmé ce dimanche aux
clayes-sous-bois cinq candidats
s'affrontent pour être à la tête de la
commune olivier augustin anne-claire
frémont nicolas us téphany jamin et
enfin philippe guiga une présentation de
ses candidats avec manon varaldo aux
clayes-sous-bois cinq candidats se pose
pour devenir le maire de cette commune
de 17 1842 habitants lutte ouvrière
faire entendre le camp des travailleurs
investi huit candidats dans les yvelines
parmi eux olivier augustin tête de liste
aux clayes-sous-bois c'est une troisième
candidature après 2008 et 2014
déjà menées à l'époque par olivier
augustin employé chez renault flins le
candidat souhaite faire entendre la voix
des travailleurs
à un moment donné bah oui il faudra que
on continue à se mobiliser qu'on
continue comme ce qui a été l'occasion
avec les gilet jaune puis avec les ehpad
puis avec les hospitaliers puis là
contre la réforme des retraites
eh bien il faudra continuer aux
clayes-sous-bois à se mobiliser pour
faire vraiment entendre notre notre
colère anne-claire frémont tête de lice
les clayes-sous-bois c'est vous et
sapeurs pompiers depuis 35 ans dans la
commune adjointe à l'éducation
parmi ces propositions la candidate
souhaite mettre en place un programme
d'adoption d'animaux domestiques par des
seniors isolés en partenariat avec les
refuges par un partenariat avec les
refuges alentours afin de permettre aux
personnes âgées d'adopter des animaux de
compagnie et du coup rompre l isolement
et pour la personne âgée et pour
l'animal de compagnie autre candidat
nicolas huet de liste l'autre projet
pour les clayes-sous-bois le conseiller
municipal d'opposition souhaite
rassembler et faciliter les déplacements
des que les siennes etc les siens nous
souhaitons redonner une réelle cohérence
et un vrai vivre ensemble à l'ensemble
de la commune notamment en développant
des circulations qui permettent aux
habitants de se rendre dans d'un
lieu à l'autre d'un quartier à un autre
quatrième candidate stéphanie jamin pour
la tête de liste énergie positive les
élections municipales se déroulent dans
un contexte d'urgence environnementale
dont son équipe en fait une priorité
la végétalisation des espaces publics ça
passe par les îlots de fraîcheur dans
les cours mais également des jardins
partagés récupérer l'espace public
également au niveau des bâtiments
publics il ya tout un travail à faire
sur les économies d'énergie faire un
audit énergétique tout simplement
enfin philippe guez ancien directeur
financier dans le secteur aéronautique
et de la défense
parmi les propositions de cet élu depuis
le candidat souhaite la création d'une
maison pluridisciplinaire de santé dans
le bâtiment de l'ancienne sécurité
sociale une maison pluridisciplinaire de
santé qui est dit pluridisciplinaire dit
effectivement médecins aussi bien
généralistes que spécialiste mais aussi
paramédicaux au niveau des médecins
je n'exclus pas même d'embaucher des
médecins au niveau de la municipalité à
maurepas il faudra faire un choix entre
l'une des quatre listes en course pour
ce scrutin notamment celle portée par
erwan le gall bonsoir mon sens est
grande car vous êtes donc à la tête de
mort pas autrement c'est une liste
divers droite il s'agit d'ailleurs de
votre première candidature comme tête de
liste pour des élections municipales
là on est à j moins 5 du premier tour
est ce que votre campagne se poursuit
est ce qu'elle est terminée à maman elle
se poursuit dans les rades dans les
règles législatives évidemment du code
électoral et will se poursuivre jusqu'à
vendredi minuit alors précision vous
êtes l'ancien premier adjoint de la
commune où le maire sortant grégory à
gary astier est également candidat
pourquoi vouloir devenir mère pourquoi
vouloir devenir mère parce que il me
semblait important de saisir cette
opportunité pour plusieurs raisons la
première sur un plan purement politique
depuis quelques années depuis françois
hollande jusqu'à maintenant je vois que
le pouvoir d'achat des françaises et des
français commencent à se déliter
fortement et je pense réellement que sur
nos repas il est important aussi de
jouer un rôle pour être sur un plan
économique sérieux et responsable le
maire à ce rôle il peut favoriser le
pouvoir d'achat le premier le premier
rôle à avoir c'est ne pas augmenter les
impôts
première chose et ne pas augmenter tout
ce qui est à point direct tout ce qui
est lié aux charges de comptines tout ce
qui est lié au périscolaire
conservatoire et c'est donc ça c'est
vraiment un engagement important
deuxième chose c'est que comme vous le
savez notre liste divers droite centre
jusqu'à une droite modérée et il n'y a
pas eu de compromission avec l'aéro même
sommes la seule liste sans des policiers
l om
voilà donc oui je pense que c'était un
enjeu important
pourquoi vouloir être mère je vais vous
répondre
également parce que nous nous sommes
portés par une équipe qui a la volonté
d'agir pour le meurent pas aidé même
occasion mais si on parle de votre liste
vous en disiez de mort on précise que
vous êtes le président du comité vie n'a
d'objectif france qu'un rassemblement de
la société civile et d'élus terrain est
ce que la liste est à l'image justement
d'objectifs france est-ce que ça
rassemble diverses personnalités divers
talents alors il vous a pas échappé que
nous avons huit étudiants sur la liste
trois chefs d'entreprise quatre anciens
élus des gens qui viennent du de la
formation du social et du sanitaire et
puis d'autres d'autres de ses d'autres
secteurs par je ne souhaite pas
rapproché objectif france avec cette
liste parce que nous avons démarré très
tard et il n'y a pas un engagement
politique liée à objectif france mais je
dois le signal est oui qu'il ya eu de
coup de téléphone du président
d'objectif france et du général soubelet
pour m'encourager
elle me dire que la vision du montage de
la liste était effectivement en écho
avec les valeurs de objectif france sont
des élections municipales où la majorité
en tous cas l'ancienne majorité à
laquelle vous appartenez vous
apparteniez par diviser ce que ce n'est
pas une voie ouverte ça justement pour
l'opposition le fait que la majorité par
diviser pour ces élections
écoutez moi j'ai l'impression que
surtout que
elle est divisée parce qu'en face en
face de nous de notre liste mort pas
autrement
j'ai trois 3 listes différentes certes
mais qui se rapprochent chaussures de
certaines thématiques la première
m'échappe acquis à 2 du lr om et puis
grégory grassi qui a du rer ont déjà ils
ont un point commun
et puis il s'appelle awad qui a lui une
ouverture beaucoup plus à gauche que que
nous vous avez été tout de même premier
adjoint de la commune les grands
incidents est ce que ça vous assumer
totalement le bilan de dix portes et
j'assume une partie du bilan d'ailleurs
j'en ferais pas bientôt
bien sûr que je suis à partir du vide
ans parce que il doit être partagée
d'ailleurs évidemment
j'assume - certaines choses où nous
avons été phagocyté sur sur des actions
en interne
voilà parce qu'il ya la démocratie
interne donc ça évidemment je je je le
regrette profondément
mais je crois profondément qu'il y à des
actions à mener au niveau de maurepas et
arrêté un petit peu ces clivages
vraiment nous avons et nous conduisons
une liste responsables allemands
alors justement sur ces projets vous
souhaitez mettre en avant une gestion
saine et est responsable de la mairie
est notamment sur le projet de futur
centre aquatique il faut selon vous au
recalibrage reprise juste les choses le
projet est mené avec elancourt et doit
voir le jour en 2022 et un contrat
délégation de service public a été signé
je le dis haut et fort il y aura
l'ouverture de la piscine lorsque nous
arriverons responsabilités en 2022
très clairement il n'est pas question
d'arrêter ce projet par contre nous
avons un temps donné d'ici 2022 pour
revoir avec le délégataire et la ville
d'elancourt parce que c'est pas une
action que je mènerai ça c'est une
action qu'on va mener avec nos
partenaires pour recalibrer salembre de
choses tout simplement pour que nous
soyons sur un niveau de dépenses qui
étaient au haut niveau initial si on
veut être en dessous encore mieux
voilà ce qui est dit actuellement que
avant
les dépenses de la piscine était de 1
million 2 ce qu'annonce le maire sortant
c'est un projet qui est chiffré à 24 3
millions d'après ce qui a été votée au
dernier jour d'accord c'est voter comme
ça on le compare par rapport à ce qui
existait avant 1 millions de spams ils
ont deux déjà c'était huit cent mille
euros puisqu'il y avait les recettes à
rentrer pour faire l'équation et la
soustraction d'accord ensuite j'ai
assisté mois aux réunions avec le
délégataire et il était initialement
prévu un million par 1 60% pour meurent
pas 40% pour elancourt nous sommes plus
du tout on ces montants là ça c'est a
recalibré ou en fait c'est du bon sens
faisons des choses modestement
modérément les qui soit en adéquation
avec les besoins de la commune elancourt
maurepas et autres et puis voyons au
bout de 5 6 ans si ça fonctionne
correctement
nous refaisons une hawks une action une
activité différente plus grands voilà
tout simplement si la gestion de bon
père de famille un autre axe puisque le
temps avance dans cet entretien
l'environnement forcément ça un thème
qui revient souvent dans cette campagne
vous souhaitez vous mettre en place un
bilan carbone à mort passe est publié
chaque année ce bilan terrebonne il n'y
a pas de bilan carbone à maurepas bon
moment oui nous voulons le faire je
trouve que c'est essentiel il n'y a pas
que ça dans les mots cratie
participative et le rs dans notre pays
et resterons a mis un certain nombre dax
qu'il faut mettre en place avec aussi
toutes les actions communes à 2 des
investissements et de la gestion au
quotidien
voilà le rsc un mot fort l'entreprise
qui déploient les airs et se moquent si
nous l'avons mis et nous l'avons
institué comme ça c'est pas par hasard
c'est que ça nous engage il y aura un
adjoint dédié uniquement à ce faire le
bilan carbone
oui derrière il faut qu'ils aient des
actions fortes et vous avez évoqué la
démocratie participative là où à
maurepas il ya des budgets participatifs
qui sont déjà proposés vous allez il
faut aller plus loin qui sont limitées à
150 mille euros bon écoute et on a vu
les limites de l'exercice voilà sans
commentaire par contre ce que nous
proposons c'est sur les investissements
des projets clés qui lie à à mettre en
place sans remous repas et celle et
mauro poggia n'aimeront pas ça qui vont
choisir deux projets au choix l'un ou
l'autre et on avancera chaque année
comme ça ça peut être même trois quatre
cinq six projets par an dans tous les
cas ça sera au moment pas et n'auront
pas besoin de choisir
ça c'est la vraie démocratie
participative c'est pas du saupoudrage
merci r ouais merci d'être venus en
plateau tête de liste de maurepas
autrement et face à vous pour ce scrutin
est le maire sortant grégory qualifiés
et les deux conseillers municipaux
d'opposition ismaila vannes et michel
chapa à magny les hameaux les habitants
auront à choisir entre deux candidats le
maire sortant bertrand ou lyon est à
nouveau et de nouveaux tête de liste et
vise une troisième mandature une équipe
renouvelée de moitié et un programme
porté sur la continuité des actions déjà
engagées sur la transition écologique et
sur le désenclavement de la commune les
propos sont accueillis par mélanie poker
une offre de transport adapté aux
besoins plus conséquente mais aussi d'un
travail sur des alternatives aux
véhicules particuliers notamment du
partage de véhicules de covoiturage avec
des zones stop entre guillemets
matérialisée au sol dans la ville le
lien avec des applications notamment
celles qui sont portées par
l'agglomération aujourd'hui et puis
déploiement de bornes électriques dans
la ville des déploiements encore de
réseau cyclable mais la campagne pour
les élections municipales qui se
poursuit également à villepreux
l'ancienne adjointe au maire sylvie se
vend à montels et tête de liste aussi
pour ce scrutin elle continue d'aller à
la rencontre des habitants avec certains
de ses colistiers elle parcourt des
quartiers de la ville pour dévoiler son
programme et échanger nicolas kirilow
vide c'est mélanie poké parfois les
portes restent fermées parfois elle
s'ouvre avec le sourire
à quelques jours des élections
municipales opération porte-à-porte pour
des membres de la liste tous pour
villepreux
l'ancienne adjointe au maire sylvie ce
vent monte elle dévoile son programme et
notamment sa position sur un projet qui
fait débat à villepreux la construction
de 250 nouveaux logements dans le
secteur du tri yann
on va arriver d'ici pas très longtemps à
13000 14000 on va mettre un pied un gros
coup de pied sur le frein sur le
développement de l'urbanisme a dit le pr
je pense que c'est vraiment plus que
raisonnable il faut absolument qu'on
trouve un équilibre urbanistique un
équilibre environnemental
il est 8 heures en équilibre financier -
de construction et plus de verts ce sont
les principales orientations de la
campagne de la candidate pour
l'environnement elle souhaite surtout
sensibiliser les plus jeunes des villes
provient on fera de la prévention
beaucoup plus dans les écoles ce que je
pense que c'est pas trés ça se verra pas
tout de suite mais un maire doit aussi
agir pour les 10 15 ans qui viennent
ça se verra pas tout de suite mais les
enfants d'aujourd'hui dans les primaires
seront des enfants des adultes
responsables plus tard je serai
certainement plus là pour le voir mais
ça n'a aucune importance pour tenter de
convaincre les habitants de voter pour
elle sylvie ce vent monte elle organise
une dernière réunion publique le
vendredi 13 mars à l'école gérard
philipe
et puis direction coignières élu depuis
2018 le maire sortant didier fischer est
de nouveau candidat il est la tête de
liste d'un élan durable pourquoi hier
l'homme politique inscrit 40 proposition
dans son programme on écoute justement
est les différentes thématiques ciblées
au micro de nicolas kirillovitch ce que
je voudrais c'est faire de coignières
une ville à vivre véritablement pour
toutes les générations
une ville exemplaire aussi en dans le
domaine du développement durable dans le
domaine de la participation citoyenne et
dans l'accès à la culture
je pense que c'est les trois points
aujourd'hui qui reste faible encore ici
sur notre ville et j'ai bien l'intention
dans les années qui viennent dans les
six ans qui viennent de développer
je dirais cette participation citoyenne
[Musique]
allez on termine ce journal avec cet
événement fort du sud et bim qui débute
demain la 6e quinzaine des possibles se
déroule jusqu'au 25 mars à rambouillet
cycle de rencontres autour de plusieurs
thématiques et trois axes la nature la
société et l'alimentation on en parle
avec françoise bernard bonsoir ça vous
êtes la présidente de l'association des
rencontres citoyennes qui co organise le
rendez vous avec la librairie
labyrinthes déjà la veille de cet
événement pas de risque à lui la scion
en raison du coronavirus pour l'instant
on sera pas mille personnes
malheureusement en même temps on
attendra donc tout est maintenu alors
c'est la sixième édition de cet
événement je le disais avec beaucoup de
choses au programme on va détailler tout
ça dans un instant déjà le principe de
cette quinzaine des possibles quel est
il le principe c'est de se faire
rencontrer des citoyens qui a envie de
comprendre et d'agir et des experts
qu'ils soient auteurs réalisateurs
enseignants qu'ils aient fait le tour du
monde à pied voilà donc c'est vraiment
cette rencontre donc c'est vraiment
créer ce lien ce lien qu'on peut perdre
à l'échelle de nos communes on peut être
rapidement dans un métro boulot dodo et
donc recréer du lien et profiter de ses
temps des changes pour apprendre et pour
peut-être mettre en place des nouvelles
choses mais c'est important que les
citoyens se saisisse de ces sujets alors
on peut parler de tous au sein de cette
quinzaine mais c'est vrai que sont
abordés notamment trois grands traits
trois grands thèmes pardon la nature la
société l'alimentation ça c'est
important qu'ils se saisissent de ces
sujets mais je pense que la nature on va
pas parler tous les rapports
scientifiques qu'on peut lire tous les
jours entre les fondements de la
biodiversité la disparition s'éteint
externe donc oui on nous enseigne pas
suffisamment le lien à la nature ensuite
la société va le vivre ensemble et vivre
ensemble partager un territoire recréer
de la solidarité
et puis l'alimentation
trois fois par jour à minima nous
alimentons et donc la question de
l'origine de la production de finalement
le territoire les paysages qu'on veut
avoir
tout ça c'est des sujets qui sont je
pense au coeur de l'actualité et
notamment en ce moment en période
électorale ou pré électoral avec un
événement qui est itinérant il y aura
des choses au théâtre le nickel à la
lanterne à la librairie labyrinthes au
poney club à la bergerie nationale tout
ça c'est à rambouillet et plusieurs
temps forts aussi dans ce programme
d'ailleurs ça se clôturera le 25 mars
avec un grand débat sur repenser la
relation en vivant c'est ça c'est ça
alors nous avons la chance d'avoir un
éminent sociologue qui s'appelle edgar
morin qui aura 99 ans au mois de juillet
donc voilà c'est assez rare et puis il
sera accompagné de gilles boeuf qui
était directeur du muséum d'histoire
naturelle et qui est un des défenseurs
et un des ambassadeurs de la
biodiversité passionnant à un moment
assez rare d'ailleurs si on regarde la
programmation c'est assez varié il ya de
la conférence aussi des ciné rencontres
notamment avec des réalisateurs
oui notamment marie monique robin qui a
réalisé son dernier film s'appelle
nouvelles cordes etc et sur l'initiative
territoire zéro chômeur qui existe dans
plusieurs régions en france ou en
embauchant des chômeurs ont créé des
activités avec atd quart monde qui
permet à la fois une on va dire une
réinsertion à nouveau né dans une
histoire de lien on a une histoire
d'activité voilà on aura la chance aussi
d'avoir anne-sophie novel sur la
question des médias de l'infobésité
finalement du rapport qu'on a envie
d'avoir aux informations et enfin
pascale d'erm sur la sylve aux thérapies
et le bienfait des arbres forêt de
rambouillet je pense que ça peut être
intéressant de comprendre ce que des
chercheurs au japon en suède ou ailleurs
ont pu analyser depuis une vingtaine
d'années et on voit que dans l'image un
quelques-unes des images des
documentaires qui sont seront proposées
une question plus pratique pour terminer
pour assister à ces programmations est
ce qu il faut réserver
alors le mieux les soirées en librairie
c'est de réserver auprès de la librairie
labyrinthes donc et à rambouillet le
téléphone c'est 09 61 22 89 91 toutes
les informations sur la page facebook
qui s'affiche ici c'est clair et pour la
soirée du 24 mars qui est la bergerie
nationale avec perrine hervé-gruyer de
la ferme du bec hellouin dont on a
beaucoup entendu parler depuis cinq six
ans sur la permaculture
il ya un lien sur wiiz event voilà
pour se préserver c'est gratuit en
revanche pour la soirée à la lanterne
est également un lien weezevent et là
c'est une entrée payante
et il faut aussi réservés il reste plus
beaucoup de place et ça débute donc dès
demain rendez-vous pour la première
conférence à la librairie labyrinthes à
20h merci françois vernay d'être venu en
parler en plateau président de
l'association des rencontres citoyennes
et je rappelle cette quinzaine des
possibles c'est du 11 au 25 mars à
rambouillet voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de l'avoir suivi belle
soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]
oh